what's up good humans this was one of
our most requested episodes so we've
heard you when I first trying to figure
forgive myself I'm like okay I wiped
another human being off the face of the
earth like how do I forgive myself how
do I ever come back from this Asian
families like we're super conservative
we don't talk about her feelings or
anything like that it's just like did
you do your homework okay good my first
visit in prison we're like we're
actually in person was like the first
time my mom's ever hugged me in life you
know it was just like okay you're doing
good I just feel really fulfilled by my
relationships after going through that
and really like when you're going
through your worst
that's when a they're like oh yeah you
reach out and build on top of those
relationships or like you just let it
falter and you just shut everybody out
like Pink's hair like our agent we never
tell each other we love her I remember
for me it was in prison that was the
first time I was able to tell my mom
that I love her I really [ __ ] with my
family and my friends is a lot more
meaningful and strong today than what it
was during time when I came to prison a
lot of my family members older seeing me
you know they favorite nephew their
favorite grandchild go through this they
were stressing out crying I got some
have a heart attack in front of me a
seizure and I bothered me a lot of them
passed on never got a chance to see me
walk up on the president it's like a
good and bad with prison because it's
like it's like a metamorphosis that you
go through because of this situation you
have to sit in whatever you've done but
at the same time you get to you know
transform yourself into something better
[Music]
I've been out of the over two weeks and
and in the process it's been a little
easier than what I thought it was going
to be I'm just ready to get to get the
ball rolling I'm 43 oh I'll have no time
to be playing so I'm kind of like on it
right now
and I know it's gonna be struggles I
know it's going to be challenges but I'm
prepared for that to over 25 years
I wasn't fearful just because like I had
a set date I went in I was married so
the plan was like we're going to do this
do this do this so I was just fortunate
that I did have people around me again
even in prison I had people around me
that were like you know you can get out
and do this it was always options I
never felt helpless I was terrified of
getting out of prison I went in at 19 I
got out at 33 I know exactly all my
friends who are now aerospace engineers
and doctors everything I'm like I have
no work experience I have nothing to put
on my resume I have no job you know
prospects what if I fail and my family
has to continue taking care of me it
scared the crap out of me more so than
staying in prison I knew that prison
messed me up like mentally like just day
in and day out of them telling you that
you have no value and you're nothing I
knew that that was like in my brain but
I think you've done the most of that
fear though look what you done now since
you've been home I don't think you've
done good for yourself thank you
it was six of us on my case and they
gave us all six the same charge music I
take full responsibility this is what
they say you're guilty of this which are
charges is even I didn't pull the
trigger even though I didn't do on other
things to other people do it was like
you know all six of us go commit a crime
boss six of us didn't participate but
all of us cuz I got charged the same
thing was a vengeful person years ago
and I was a retaliated individual and I
end in my best friend's life and I
received life and it was absolutely fair
but it wasn't fair for their family
because I can still see my family so I
agree it did take me a second to forgive
myself because I think for any of us
like where we were hardest on ourselves
you know do something wrong and
everybody else will forgive us but we
don't forget our so so it took me a
while but I have owning it and then
forgiving myself on that so that's why
I'm kind of just somewhat agree for me
it was hard just based on like um like
my father passed when I was in prison
for years I had dreams about him that's
what made it hard for me to like get
over it but I think once I kind of like
facing him actually grieved that loss
that's one of it would actually move
forward so watch my mom drive out every
single weekend and camp out in front of
the prison overnight and she would come
in and sit there at visiting and she'd
be so exhausted she just fall asleep
when I was twenty I was like ma just go
home like just go home and go to sleep
but I didn't realize that she did that
because she loved me that much now
knowing that she went through all of
that for me it's tough to forgive
yourself for that
you know when I'm first trying to figure
forgive myself I'm like okay I wiped
another human being off the face of the
earth like how do I forgive myself how
do I ever come back from this but I
figured if I sit there and hold on to
that there's there's no moving forward
so if I really feel bad and if I want to
forgive myself then how to kind of make
sure there's no more victims how can I
make sure that I can make a better life
for myself and other people around me
[Music]
life for me it goes down in like history
basically the first sheriff's badge was
the slave patrol so coming down that
line from slave control to the chain
gang to mass incarceration so like the
justice system I somewhat agree that
it's like because it was created to do
what he does he's doing what's supposed
to it wasn't made for me or by me so it
does its function as far as I'm
concerned the justice system is you know
based on how the prosecutor can bolster
his success rate in court because that's
how they get into private practice right
it's sort of like our political system
they're not gonna go for you know soft
on crime laws because they don't get in
elected into the next thought you know
term same thing with the prosecutors
they're not gonna you know try a case
where they're not so sure about or
they're gonna like stack their case
against you because they want to bolster
their their success rates so that they
can get into private practice and make
even more money you're right because two
people with the exact same charge
depends with a defender or paid lawyer
public subjects public defender paid
lawyer county that you gotta rest that
state you gotta rest of that like I mean
there you go across the board it's great
you can do from like two years to a life
sentence on any charge besides those
that are innocent and I do agree with a
lot of things he said when this first
came about I used to tell some of my
friends oh it's my attorneys fault I got
25 delay well it's my upbringing when I
got 25 to life but I realized that laws
were in place and justice system to
protect society and our own families as
well I didn't put the gun in my
attorneys hand I didn't put the gun in
the judges hand or the jury
I'm the one that put myself in that and
when I got the 25 to life
I understood and I accepted it I totally
respect your viewpoint I just feel like
it's two separate issues you know I take
responsibility for I still don't think
the game's fair right like they lock us
up boy for years don't provide any way
for us to really better ourselves and
then on your release date here's 200
bucks get out of here don't get in
trouble again like I have no idea how to
find a job I have no idea how to cope I
have no idea how to process you know my
mental state of my emotional state I was
lucky enough to have support but there
are a lot of people we know like their
parole English under a bridge you know
it's like what is the system doing for
them
[Music]
I mean I had all those fears my family's
like just keep your head down everyone's
like don't say what you're in for and
I'm like I'm in for fraud you know and I
just kept my head low I'm like that's it
that's all right basically knew I was
coming home but it was an adventure a
lot of my friends died at Tina's
teenagers 16 17 years old the area I
grew up in you know it was you know you
didn't even ever see 21 I have no
friends that I grew up with playing
peewee league all that there are going
so my mother looked at this as this this
is what saved me my very first cellmate
was a lifer you know who like murdered
his wife and cold blood and we didn't
get along and you know he one night he
put a citrus ID in my food like
industrial cleaner and my food and like
I caught him like well what am I
supposed to do now and you know you know
I talked to the guys are like you got to
handle it you know I was just a kid you
know and there were definitely times
where I didn't think I was gonna make it
out that's the biggest fear is getting
stabbed for somebody else messing up and
then or the cops just shooting and
missing or hitting us yeah
[Music]
you know you have a [ __ ] voice and
you're not everything that got the
guards tell you you are you're not
everything the prosecutor said you are
you're not everything that you know the
wardens and the system says you are
right like the way they treated us like
animals I just thrown us on the wall and
like strip searches and you know coming
into your cell and like tearing up all
your stuff like that's not who we are
well a lot of person I am today I have
the more appreciation for the smaller
things I truly believe that every human
beings worth salvaging
and I say that all the time so that's
why I like regardless of our mistakes in
the past with the choices we made that's
that's why I believe like I'm not
dictated by my past man like we have
such different experiences and the fact
that we come from very different places
I think it's there's just very
enlightening to watch one more thing you
guys were actually doing an episode with
cops but we're having trouble finding
cops so Kendra email Kendra if you know
any cops or officers would love to be in
an episode because we want to humanize
cops and tell their stories to it and if
you are not a cop when you'd like to be
an episode also fill out the custom form
below we're looking for just Laura
amazing all the good humans to be part
of this so we'd love to hear from
absolutely as always like subscribe
leave a comment below follow us on
Instagram I will see you next time